the Coast Guard has suspended its search
for survivors following a deadly boat
fire off the coast of California newly
released video shows the vessel burning
near Santa Barbara Monday morning we're
also learning more about the 34 people
feared dead Meg Oliver spoke with a man
who lost five members of his own family
she's in Stockton California meg the
families are hoping for answers today
what do you know they certainly are Tony
good morning the National Transportation
Safety Board is joining the
investigation its final report could
take months
yesterday we talked to Dominick selgeh
his family was on board and they took a
trip on the boat every year you don't
want to believe it he went to hold on to
that 1% but at this point it's you know
my heart knows Dominic's Olga says his
mother stepfather and three stepsisters
[Music]
we're among the 34 presumed dead aboard
the dive boat Concepcion it burst into
flames and sank off the Santa Barbara
coast early Monday morning people on
nearby boats described it as pure horror
to watch helplessly watching those
flames they were down there in those
bunks they're really small bunks to have
no escape it was something that was just
plain in my head it was just a complete
nightmare on Tuesday rescuers continued
efforts to recover the bodies of those
trapped below deck the FBI visited a
sister ship owned by the same tour
company with a similar layout as
Concepcion never thought I would ever
have to go through this Shari McDonough
says her 25 year old daughter was on
board she loved it here and she loved
the boat she loved diving also among the
passengers experienced diver Christie
Finn's dad the 41 year old was on the
ship to lead a scuba tour the boat's
wreckage now rests upside down on the
ocean floor divers will also map a
search area which is about a half mile
in size in our continuing efforts to
recover additional victims and evidence
meanwhile family members are being asked
to provide DNA to help identify the
victims
there was an extraordinarily hot fire
and the bodies do exhibit signs of
extreme thermal damage for Soga he just
wants answers for his mother if there
was one thing that you could say to your
mom what would it be if there was one
thing I can say my mom I love you and
that's it
fellas family was on board to celebrate
his stepfathers birthday he would have
turned 61 years old today the NTSB says
they are 100% confident they will be
able to determine what caused this fire
maria elena heartbreaking meg thank you